we've got under our belts in your mind
and also on this a whole bunch of
formulas from measuring stuff right for
measuring areas with your perimeters
very different volumes all that good
stuff but the one thing that all of
these formulas have in common is that
they have to be on a particular shape
right it's got to be a rectangle it's
gotta be a parallelogram both sides they
got to be exactly parallel if they just
like off a little bit your formulas
stuffed okay I love your circle I see
perfectly around your sphere etc so in
other words they're these very
specialized shapes and if you're just a
little bit off therefore those useless -
okay
but the thing is the real world is full
of these shapes in fact in a real way
like this is example I always use my
watch right it's no one I wear every day
I've won five years yeah looks like the
face of the watch is circular
it looks like it's circular but if
you've got like I've been quite rough
with this one
if you got like a microscope that and
you zoomed in on the edge you're fine
it's like super bumpy and jagged and
it's got heaps of dents in them because
I'm not very careful in it now for that
reason you can really use the area of a
circular formula on this because it's
not moving so much
okay and in real life you get shapes
that don't obey nice - the rules about
what kinds of like how parallel their
sides are or whether the opposite edges
are equal right well you got weird
shapes like this what do you do really
smart mathematician named Simpson you
came up with a rule that could take a
reader looking shaped like this with
curved edges or lots a weird straight
edges and approximate the area it's not
gonna be exact but you need to be exact
a lot of the times long as you're close
enough you can work out or how much is
it gonna cost so put pub this wing with
grass or pave it over or whatever okay
so I'm going to show you the formula I'm
going to show you the way that it works
and I'm gonna give you so mum enough
courts that it will help you use the
formula shape with this so here's a
particular kind of area that what I've
done is I've got some salado's straight
sides that I've measured out
and then I've got this read wonky side
over here okay now the way that I've
done it is that these straight parts are
all built into our thing so think about
how we did that field diagram do you
remember that it's like okay you walk
across the diagonal and then one of you
stood in the middle and then someone
else walked off at right angles and then
you like you you had your with you're
trying to wheel and you measured out
however many meters that was so what we
want is for these distances to be the
same they're called H for height so you
kind of like look at this diagram
sideways and then these three distances
here just like on a field diagram you
need to measure what they are because
they're all distances we made with them
all with the letter D but because
there's three of them we call only ten
to call them the first distance so
that's DF the middle distance let's do
em and the last is hands
so that's DL okay so they're all
distances so we all use the letter D for
all of them but I did not choose the
order of the letters first little last
that's what it stands for
okay just so you can tell them apart
you could but the reason why I'm using
these particular labels is because the
formula sheet is these all right here
comes the actual formula right if I'm
working out an area and I have all these
four measurements on here
it will be approximately equals to equal
to here's the rule it's a little bit
awkward but you take whatever this um
this interval distance is here and it's
the same each time divided by three and
then you multiply it by this Riaan
the first distance for lots of the
middle distance and the last distance
okay now that's a bit weird and random
there is so fancy schmancy theory and
that's behind where this formula comes
from you can ask you about that later on
if you're curious but the important
thing is it does an amazingly good job
of getting an approximation of this area
okay so if I were to you're just gonna
develop a unit if I were to know I'm
just to give some examples of some
distance to you so suppose this is 10
meters and this antenna is let's put
some lights on here that was 10 I don't
know and this looks like it's about 16
meters that's about the same you knew of
it this is a little bit let's go back so
as an example how am I gonna use this
alright just quote the area is
approximately equal to here's the height
the height of each of these chunks so
each of them is 10 it's the it's
important they're the same so I'm gonna
go to 10 over 3 and then I'm gonna
multiply by okay you just go one he's
the first one 60 he's the middle one I'm
gonna do four of them so that's 4 times
10 and I missed the last one
now the four is part of the formula it's
part of the formula now you might be
like why is there a four bit again I
can't explain but it's quite actually
takes quite a lot of time and it's very
difficult okay
what's amazing is how well it works
let's just quickly evaluate sixteen plus
40 plus 8 56 64 640 divided by 3 that's
going to be 230 point 3 it's a Wow okay
so what I've got here is a an
approximation point now just quickly
this is an approximation how can I tell
you now I say I'll do a sense check as
much as you possibly can is this
reasonable okay what I'm going to try is
like what else could I use to
approximate this check what else could I
use to well I've got these up these
perpendicular lines see okay don't draw
this just follow along with me cuz I'll
eyes will make a mess of your diagram as
I'm about to you okay let's just say
what if we imagine these were straight
right like that line there and that line
in just pretend okay now if there was
straight
what would this overall shape be with
the overall shape it will be a trapezium
right because you've meant to get these
bits which are parallel to each other so
I know the area of a trapezium the area
of a trapezium is H onto a plus B what's
the H in this case it's the height of
the trapezium so in this case the height
of the hole it appears you would be 20
do you see that like I'm just trying it
as partner
what are the a and B yeah it's the it's
the parallel of science degree at that
so 16 plus 8 okay um this is 10 16 plus
8 is 24 so it's 240 ok now this is
probably not right this is probably not
right because as you can see I have
taken these like this straight part
these curvy parts rather and then
replace them with straight lines clearly
that's going to be a problem ok but at
least I know I'm in the right ballpark
Purfleet like yeah it's not like I'm 10
times on jimweiss is being I put more
money on this being a better answer